well we're over this that's more over an
hour oh really yeah we'll just call in
all the time Jade Jade caterpillar thank
you for the pizza thank you for the
thank you for the pizza thanks for the
pizza brought you're online you're on
the I mean you're online you're on
you're on the podcast dad
you're online but are you in Australia
or in LA she's back here oh you're in
Brazil SAR Austral she is leaving foster
alien why are you going to Australia all
right
so if you're Australian all your fans
out there go see Jake at a Beretta
called Jade cata Preta very what so
anyway so if you're an austrial check it
out and you did some guest-starring
right what what you guest star on future
your reoccurring I mean interviewing you
know no Jade when you come on to the
[ __ ] pot guys would we get into it
this is just surface Colin [ __ ] yeah
okay thank you
I love you
I okay that's it that's the last one
she's great
he's a pizza good it's really um I
haven't eaten yet what kind is it bacon
cheese basically not expensive Italian
already
[Music]